- [Heitor] Hello, thank you
for joining us in this session.
My name is Heitor, and I'm here with Stan.
We are both from the AWS
Professional Service team,
and we are here today to
talk about our experience
helping the AWS Professional
Service organization
adopt coding agent
and lessons learned that
we accumulated so far.
So you're gonna see
that we are gonna start
with this problem statement
to help set the stage,
understand the common trap that we have,
this blindfolded coding agent, a problem.
Then we are gonna go
and talk about how can we mitigate
and avoid this problem.
And to start like,
have you ever experienced this situation
like you are assigned to a project,
and now that coding agent, it's available,
everyone expecting to deploy
things in lightning speed,
and now you have the experience saying,
can this coding agent generate
an authentication system
from my e-commerce platform?
And right after a few minutes,
you're gonna get an output.
First time it looks okay,
like everything is using the latest
and greatest spec or documentation.
And when you look deeper
the documentation is there,
so it's pretty well structured and so on,
but then reality hits the ground.
So you're gonna dive deeper
and see that the agent's not
following the session manager
that you have in your
front-end environment.
Basically all those requirements
that you have for single
sign-on in your enterprise,
and finally just to keep it simple
like it's volunteer itself
to generate more features
that you didn't ask.
And this is exactly what we mean
by fast code isn't necessary good code,
and even good code is eventually
not the right code for you.
So 'cause there are many
ways to implement things,
but you need to implement things
following the compliance or the rules
that you have in your organization.
Just to put this into a
different perspective,
to illustrate this,
if you think on your right-hand side,
you have the target like
your desired solution,
and you're using the code agent
to implement that feature for you.
If you don't provide enough context
about how you're gonna build this system
and give the guidance how to do that,
eventually it's basically using
the coding agent blindfolded,
and it's trying to guess
navigating through this ambiguity
to get to the target.
It may or may not deliver what you need.
And this session that is gonna be
about how can we prevent that?
The good news is, Kiro
has a lot of features,
built-in features that can help you
minimize the possibility of going
off of your target.
So one example is spec,
different development
that we talked so much.
It's basically how can you break down
large complex problem into
define the success criteria,
the requirements that you have,
how you design this solution
break down into tasks.
So you can think if
you're planning to drive
to a specific location,
how you plan your route to get there.
Then we have hooks,
the analogy that I put
here is like using a GPS
'cause eventually you
may get a wrong turn,
and the GPS in your car
basically is rerouting
to help you go back to the ideal course.
So you can do this in your environment
to define non-negotiable
requirements that you have.
And if something is going off the plan,
you can use this event to go
back to the original design.
Eventually you have the steering docs,
and this is one feature that
you can leverage in Kiro
to define what are intrinsic knowledge
or design principles that
you have in your organization
to basically teach Kiro to behave
like best in class the
different consultant.
So in this component,
we are trying to define to Kiro,
share our lessons learned
how to do tradeoff analysis
and how to behave when we
need to make a decision.
And finally the most common one is MCP,
so if you have a tool
that you need to access
to execute a task, it's
available there for you.
The main difference between steering docs
and MCP is how frequent
those things change.
So what I would say is,
steering docs is more design principle.
So if you think about what
(indistinct) framework
that we have, that's true
over time and persistent.
Most likely this knowledge
should be represented
as steering doc 'cause
you use this to understand
what good looks like in your environment.
And MCP is more for dynamic data,
so you don't need to throw
all AWS documentation
inside the session window
and flood the context window of the Kiro
to understand what the service
feature set is available.
You can access those things
on demand when needed.
But the main question that we have
when we are working in
ProServe specifically is,
how can we get to this level of precision?
Like I can't afford to
have this margin of errors,
or the coding agent going
rogue in different direction.
I need to be exactly grounded
on the customer requirements.
And that's when we
start this conversation,
so because most of the time
we are trying to rush into code phase
and asking the coding agent to go fast,
even if we don't know what
we are trying to build first,
and what are the possible path.
So if you want to get
this level of precision,
you need to go way back
to the notes that you have
about what you're trying to build,
translate the context from window,
the human context into a context
that I can share with the agent.
So agent can be more
effective executing the task.
So as you're gonna see,
this is all about how
can we find a balance
between what we should
put in the context window
'cause if we put too little,
the agent's gonna need to
navigate through the ambiguity,
and probably this when they
can make the wrong call.
If you put too much, it's gonna flood,
and they basically can
ignore some important notes
that you have about the project.
And worse than that, if you
have conflicting requirements,
like one specific document
is saying something
and another is saying the opposite,
how the coding agent is gonna
decide which one to pursue?
So let's do a thing like,
we are gonna start seeing
how we implement those things
inside Professional
Service to give you a sense
how to avoid those problems
that we are discussing so far.
I know these are 300 sessions,
so I'm going to use just a few minutes
to level set everyone.
Like I don't know if how many of you
have been using Kiro so far,
but just to level set
and show those components
that we discussed before.
So I just opened my environment here,
and on the left-hand
side I have my project,
and right-hand side I can start a session
using Kiro to help me do things.
So if you open the Kiro tab,
you're gonna see that we
have all those components
that I was discussing before.
So spec, the routing plan,
hooks, the GPS,
adjustment, then we
have the steering docs,
the design principle,
like I mentioned before,
and MCP, the tools that are available.
Just to give you a sense
what those things means,
I'm gonna open here
and ask Kiro to describe
those things for me.
So first question that I would ask is,
what can you do for me?
So what Kiro is available,
how can they help us build project?
And you can basically chat
with the agent right in the session,
and it's gonna say
that I'm here to assist
you code development,
I can create CLI command,
and so on and so forth.
As I mentioned before,
we have a few specs,
so if you don't want to
dive too deep what spec is,
I can basically ask Kiro to say,
can you explain to me, what's
inside this spec document?
And it's gonna try to make sense of
what you define in this spec document,
and define for you what's in there.
So let me see if I can,
I need to do this
spec design agent.
So it's thinking, analyzing
what's inside this design document,
but as we wait I can show
you actually this in the...
Okay, so it's explaining
to me exactly the problem
that I was describing at the beginning,
like how can we translate
human context into context
that's defined for our coding
agent to execute the plan.
So everything that I'm describing here
is trying to go through raw notes,
distill this information in a way
that I can hand over to our agents.
So if I go and expand this to
see how a spec is structured,
we have three main tabs here,
requirements just describing why,
what we are trying to build in these spec,
like this task list, if you will.
In this case I'm trying to say,
I want to navigate through raw data
and create what I'm calling spec package.
That's this context for agents.
Then this is how we're gonna do that.
So I've created those many stages,
but if I go to the task list,
you're gonna see that basically
I'm instructing to Kiro.
Just one second, I'm
gonna get to the list.
I'm instructing to Kiro say,
this is how you're gonna
navigate through this,
execute the task, and so on.
And we are gonna see this
in action in a minute.
The other concept that
we have here is hooks.
So the easiest way to see this,
how it works is actually
trying to create one.
So I can open Kiro here,
and as you create a new hook,
the one that I like that
resonate a lot with users
that are using this for the first time
is update my documentation.
So basically what I'm describing here is,
if I'm trying to build something,
and as soon as I save a code base,
a new file in my repo,
it's gonna go to my project
README file and update.
So the README file is always reflecting
what's actually implemented.
So if I do this Kiro behind-the-scenes
is evaluating my prompt here,
and wanna create this rule for hooks
defining what's the event that's
gonna trigger this action,
and then what we gonna do since
whenever we get this
action being triggered.
So as you're gonna see here,
this is documentation
sync, the descriptions,
every time I'm saving a
file with this extension,
we're gonna prompt the code to say,
is there any change or
significant change in my repo now
that I need to represent
in the README file?
If yes, make the relevant
change in the README file,
and keep this updated.
All right, spec, how we decompose
complex problems into task list;
hooks, how can we keep these
following non-negotiable
criteria that we have;
steering docs, I think the
easiest way is again ask Kiro.
So I have a lot of knowledge
that we put here in the
steering doc folder,
but one that resonate a lot with users
is this collaboration workflow.
And just to give an
example how this works,
I'm gonna ask Kiro to
describe what's in there.
And this is basically telling Kiro
how I want the code agent to behave.
So at the very top I'm saying,
we are working on this together.
If you'll see that I'm
asking you to do something
that's not aligned with best practice,
I prefer you to push back
and see why this is not a good idea
and keep me honest when
I should execute things.
If we are trying to do a problem solving,
I don't want to try to
get the quickest solution,
I need to go deeper and see
the root cause on those things.
And another thing in our situation is,
every time we are building stuff,
I don't want the agent
to take critical actions.
And this is things that
I'm describing here.
Please don't automatically do
Git commit, Git push, and so on.
Ask me, if you want to do
this, take those actions.
And if I ask you to do so,
confirm before executing.
So this is just an an example of things
that we describe how
I want Kiro to behave.
We have many other objects here
that we usually load as needed,
but this one specifically,
if you see at the very top,
Kiro has this option to define
the inclusion mode that we want.
So when we say always, every
single session that we load,
and one example is the very top,
everything that I put is always,
it's gonna be loaded for
every single session.
And if I put manual, let's say,
I think this one is manual.
So if I open this one,
I'm only loading this
steering doc when needed.
And MCP is the most popular one,
so let me see if I can
quickly show one example here.
I'm gonna ask Kiro to describe
what's available in this
knowledge MCP server.
And as you're gonna see,
it's gonna go through the
definition of the tools
that's inside this MCP,
and give me a sense
what's available there.
And by the way, this MCP
is available to everyone.
So if you want to leverage
these in your project,
you can include in our
development environment.
And the idea is,
I can search updated documentation of AWS,
it's gonna list the repos
that we usually consume.
So it's AWS documentation,
blogs, GitHub sample, constructs,
and all those things.
And I can basically interact with this MCP
when I need to get access to latest data.
All right, now that I know spec,
hooks, agent, steering docs, and MCP,
how can I make sense in a real scenario?
So I'm gonna close everything.
I'm gonna start with this simple project.
In this situation here,
I'm trying to simulate what
usually happen in projects.
Imagine a situation that
a person went through a
re:Invent summit or AWS summit,
and they have an idea like,
always that I go to those summits,
I have these notes that I
never consolidate well enough
when I go back to my company,
and I need to do this knowledge transfer,
I always struggle to remember
what I took notes, and so on.
So what if we have a system
that I basically take a screenshot,
add notes in my TXT
or markdown file, and so on,
and I shared this with agent,
and agent gonna make sense of this.
If I'm asking open questions,
not answering my notes,
the agent gonna be responsible
for searching for the answer,
and help me consolidate this,
so I can go back to my company
and do a knowledge transfer effectively.
The problem is, it's never
where we structure like
that person describing
what is needed to be done,
and how we're gonna execute.
Start with someone
having this idea via email,
then this move to Slack thread
that people are brainstorming
about what we should do.
Then someone else replied to
the original email saying,
what if we use the
knowledge MCP that we saw,
to answer those unanswered questions
that we have in our notes.
And then they have a meeting,
they transcribe this meeting,
then they have another session,
is like the whiteboard solution.
And now I have no clue
what I'm trying to build.
If I just ask Kiro to do that
and implement this software for me,
most likely it's gonna
try to help me somehow,
but if I don't structure this context
in a way that's gonna be effective
for coding agent to execute the plan,
most likely you don't have
what you are expecting.
So how can we
do about that?
Like how can we save,
improve this process?
Remember that I mentioned in the diagram
that we have this design agent.
Design agent is this spec doc
that I created in my
Kiro environment here.
And the way that I can call
it is basically saying,
can you execute
the tasks that I defined in design agent?
And when I go to a new session and say,
I'm gonna start this process,
it's gonna understand
that I put all those notes
about this project in that input folder.
It's gonna read all those
things and execute the task
that I defined in this workflow.
So first thing is, I need
to read all the input data.
So all those files that
in our input folder,
try to understand what
are the requirements,
non-functional requirements, risk,
and anything that we capture from there.
And then share this back with the human,
so they can validate if this is
exactly what you're trying to build.
So when you go to the build phase,
you are most likely gonna be successful
'cause you know exactly
what are the requirements,
successful criteria, and so on.
So instead of waiting this
to the end to complete,
I'm gonna skip ahead,
I have another one here that I executed,
and the output of these,
processing these input data
is in this generated folder.
So if I open here and go
to functional requirements,
for example, I'm
consolidating this in a way
that I know exactly
what I'm trying to build
in a consolidated way.
So I'm trying to create a
content upload interface.
I need to have the content storage,
I have AI power summarization
feature, and so on.
And every single requirements
that I'm listing here,
I'm trying to put clarity for Kiro,
understand what I'm actually trying,
or how I'm gonna assess the
completeness of this task.
So for this one specifically,
I'm saying this is a must
have based on the context,
and I'm showing where I
got this information from,
from the original email
in the meeting notes
that I got originally.
And this is how I captured
the successful criteria of this task.
And this is not only for
the functional requirements,
we have for non-functional
requirements as well.
So we have, I captured the response time,
the scalability criteria,
how we're gonna evaluate
the storage requirements.
And then finally,
one thing that I would
like to highlight here is,
when I was reading all this
context from the raw notes,
I'm trying to break it down in two levels.
One is business objective,
like what are the goals that my leadership
or whoever has started this
project shared at the beginning.
So as you can tell here,
we have six main
objective of this project.
So I'm trying to organize
conference learning,
improve knowledge, answer a
question that I don't have,
and help me like create,
link any post when I go back
to my company, and so on.
I can make sense of my notes,
and this is how I broke down
these into requirements.
And if I'm trying to think
about this from the project
management perspective,
I also instructed in my
workflow to create user stories,
so we know how can we
break down these into
small modules or work stream.
And in the end of the day,
what I'm trying to do here is
understand the what, like
what we are trying to build.
And one thing that I have
here just to consolidate
all those notes that we described so far,
we have many ways to represent
knowledge to a coding agent
to leverage those things when
we're executing a project.
During our experience
and to understand how you can select
which bucket you're gonna use,
I would use this approach.
Like if you're trying
to represent a workflow
like I was describing saying,
you need to read the files,
you need to extract the requirements,
you need to understand that
you need to map those things.
So if it's a very
structured workflow spec,
maybe the answer for that.
And important to understand is,
you need to to guarantee
that you are tracing
the criteria to the requirements.
And then when you create
a complex workflow,
you need to keep these handoff material.
So when you go to the
next step or next session,
the next step in your workflow,
they're gonna know what to execute next
or what you did before.
So this is basically the routing planning
that you have in your metaphor.
But if I'm trying to do
event driven automation,
like when I save something,
hooks is important,
highlight here, and
based on our experience
try to match these in a timing needed,
so when you save a file,
when you create a file.
Another important thing
is to avoid this loop,
if you're trying to edit the same file
that generated or triggered the event,
try to just list what you
should do instead of editing
and saving to avoid these
infinite loop in your environment
'cause this is your GPS routing.
So if you're making the wrong turn,
it's gonna help you go
back to the original plan.
Then when should I understand
if it's a steering doc or MCP?
One thing that I would highlight to you
is steering docs more
for design principles.
So if I need to understand
what good looks like
to make a decision between tradeoff,
this is when steering
docs, it's a good approach.
And the steering docs, the
most important part is,
this is basically when
you're trying to drive
what are the minimum amount
of information that you keep,
so the traffic laws that
you need to memorize,
to understand how to drive in a street.
So this is what you put in streering doc.
It's important to remember
the proper inclusion pattern
to avoid flooding the context.
So if you are saving everything
for always, be loaded,
probably you're gonna waste
tokens in your environment.
And finally MCPs is for dynamic content.
So if you have tools
that you need to interact to take action,
this is actually the
real-time traffic information.
So if you need to remember
something as needed,
like the real traffic information,
this is the bucket that you use
to represent this knowledge.
All right, so this is just to level set
that now we understand what
we are trying to build,
translating the human context to a context
that the coordination can behave.
But before we go to the execute,
there is another important
part to understand
among all the possible paths
that we have to execute the plan,
how can we pick the right one?
And for that I'm gonna invite
Stan to join the stage.
Oops, to share this next session,
next part of the session.
Thank you.
- [Stan] Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Stan and I will take it from here.
So now we have our agent
equipped with steering doc specifications,
hooks, and MCPs.
But is it enough for our agent
to be truly useful in real work?
Will this agent be able to write the code,
which is not only good, but
the code which is right?
Imagine this situation.
You have your advanced agent
who is capable to write
a sophisticated code
and solve complex technical problems,
and one day you are asking your agent
to provide recommendation
for your containerized application
authentication mechanism.
And your agent just
returns to your generic
of (indistinct) authentication
instead of referencing you to
approved integration patterns
for your IdP provider.
Or you are asking for a recent
AWS pricing information,
and the agent just apologizes,
but doesn't have this information.
It doesn't sounds familiar?
This is intelligence gap problem
that can affect even the
most sophisticated AI agents.
Development team often reports
that the agent can provide
technically correct,
but contextually relevant recommendation
due to lack of access to
organizational knowledge.
And it's not just a minor problem,
it's significant barrier in AI adoption
in enterprise environments
where context matters
as much as capabilities.
When developers first deploy their agents
in production environment,
we quickly realized these limitations.
The agent may be excellent
in general problem solving skills,
but it lacks a significant context,
which makes it really useful in real work.
Let's take a look into
this problem closer.
Most of organization have
available information
stored in the system, which
are locked from AI agents.
With the information such as
architecture decision records,
internal wiki pages, team standards.
Without accessing this information,
agents just use general knowledge
and cannot build on top of
experience of your organization.
From another side of this problem,
we have external knowledge problem.
Knowledge of your agents is limited
by training data cutoff time.
And it means that we don't
have access to information
about recent serious capabilities,
new function, such as functions
and services announced at re:Invent.
We might not have access to
recent pricing information,
which is important for cost
estimation and valuation,
and we don't have access
to security vulnerabilities
and purchase information
that can affect selection
of technical stacks
and technologies in new system.
And in order to solve this problem,
we need to find structured approach
which will convert your AI agents from
static knowledge repositories
into intelligent system,
which can collect, process,
and apply information from
both, internal knowledge
and external current information.
How we address this issue
in our intelligent AI agent architecture?
On the left-hand side of the diagram,
you may see components responsible
for internal knowledge processing,
and on the right-hand side
there is a part of architecture,
which processes external data.
Let's start from internal
knowledge processing.
And the first component
of our architecture
is layer of data agents.
You may think about data
agents as a specialized agents
that has tools that allows them
to connect to your internal systems,
and we have very detailed
prompt, system prompts,
which explains how this
agent should use these tools
to effectively extract information
from your internal systems.
This agent might be connected to a system,
which source reusable artifacts,
various code repositories with blueprints
and reusable components
that you can use in your architectures.
Or we can have access
to internal wiki pages
and documentation,
which stores information
about services capabilities
and limitations
and various best practices
and industry approved use cases.
When that agent extracted this information
from your internal system,
we can post this set of reusable
assets into the next layer.
On the next layer, we have
a panel of expert agents.
You may think about these
agents as specialized experts,
each of them is specialized
in a certain aspect of architecture.
We can have functional fit expert,
which determines if a component
solves core business problem,
or implements all the required features.
We can have architecture fit expert,
which determines if the component
follows the established best practices,
such as well-architected framework,
and how well it's integrated
with your internal applications.
We can have security
experts who can evaluate
if this component follows
your security best practices.
For example, does it have
proper authentication,
(indistinct) implemented,
and how it stores the data?
Does it has encryption at rest?
Or we can have operational
experts who can determine
if the specific component
is production-ready.
Each of the experts of this
panel review the components
and produce the score from zero to 100
on how well this component
fits with target architecture.
A part of a score,
each agent also produces a summary
of where this component fits
with target architecture
and where the gaps are identified.
After all the components are
evaluated by expert panels,
we can move to the next
stage of this process
where we perform ranking
and scoring of assets.
We aggregate this scores based
on each individual component,
and using this segregated score
to form a shortlist of components
we are going to use in
our target architecture.
Now let's take a look into
a part of architecture,
which is responsible for
external knowledge
aggregation and processing.
In order to collect and
process external data,
we are using implementation
of deep research framework.
If we will search over internet
for deep research
framework implementation,
most likely we'll find
whitepapers from companies
such as Anthropic,
LangChain, or Mirrorflow.
All these whitepapers
are different in details,
however, the core idea of all this work,
systems is pretty similar.
All of them are using
multi-agent architectures
to implement deep research functionality
over three major steps.
First we do job planning
when execute subtasks,
and finally we produce segregated result.
Let's take a look into this
architecture in more details.
So the core component of this architecture
is a coordinator or main agent.
The role of this agent is
to get complex user query
and split it into a list
of individual tasks.
Often coordinator is using
special tools, a reasoning tool,
which helps coordinator
to plan the activities
and perform the split of complex tasks
into sequence of independent subtasks.
And once coordinator
split this complex task
into a set of individual subtasks,
it spins up multiple sub agents,
and passes this individual subtasks
into each of sub agents.
Sub agents are responsible
for processing of the subtasks.
And in order to process this information,
agents are equipped with a set of tools
we are using to execute with our subtasks.
Once each sub agent finished
their part of a job,
we form intermediate result,
and these results are
headed back to coordinator.
Coordinator aggregates results
from multiple sub agents,
performs clean aggregations,
and produces a final result.
Let's briefly talk about this tools
we are using in our architecture.
First of all, we are
dealing with external data,
so we need instrument to
search data over internet,
so we have internet search tool.
Once we identified sources of information
and we know where exactly
this information is located,
we need to provide functionality
for our agents to read this information,
so we need some type of browser.
You may use one of open-source
implementation of browsers,
such as Chromium, headless or Playwright,
or you may choose one of
specialized components,
such as AgentCore Browser.
Our agents also have access to file system
and read and write operation,
and usually we use this operation
for intermediate results processing
and state management.
Often deep research requires accessing
specialized sources of data,
such as code repository on GitHub.
And if this is the case,
you may put MCP server,
and for example,
transitions provide the functionality
to wrap any MCP server into a tool,
which you can use in your agents.
What are lessons learned
when we built with deep
research implementation?
First of all, deep research framework
is quite a complex system
with a lot of moving parts and components,
and observability is a key component
for successful implementation
of deep research functionality.
Using proper observability,
you can quickly answer the questions,
what exactly each sub agents is doing,
what tools are available for sub agents,
how we use these tools,
and which results every
sub agent produces.
Another lesson learned for us was,
we need to understand which exact tools
are available for each sub agents,
and how sub agents are using these tools.
We found that sometimes
agents are using tools
in completely different
way from what we expected,
so it's important to make sure
that agents are using the tools
the way you are expecting.
And the final lessons learned was
that optimization of
deep research framework
is about finding proper balance
between resources you're going to spend
for your deep research analysis
and quality of output.
It means that you can
technically spend hours
and millions of tokens
without significant improvement of
quality of output results.
So it's really important to
have in place configuration,
which you can quickly where
you can quickly define
depth and breadth of a deep
research functionality.
And you can flexibly
configure this balance
to find proper balance between resources
you're going to spend,
and quality of ongoing result.
Okay, with that we will switch to a demo.
Okay, I will start at the same stage
where Heitor showed before.
So we have our demo project,
and we passed first two
stages of this project.
Just a reminder, in stage one
we analyzed input documents
and we extracted information,
what is the scope of a project
and if this project is POC
or it's fully functional application.
So all these details that we can derive
from project documentation.
And on stage two, we generated functional
and non-functional requirements
as well as traceability
metrics and user stories.
So now we can continue to the next stage,
soil type continue.
Our agent maintains the
state of the process,
so it knows exactly
where we are right now,
and it'll continue with the first task
over the next stage three.
The next stage in our process
is the generation of system
architecture documents.
And to begin of this process,
our agent checks if we
have access to our backend.
Our backend that we discussed before
is available to our
agent through MCP server.
So this one, intelligence hubs here
provides access for our
Kiro agent to our backend,
which takes care of both,
with internal and external information.
When this MCP server is available,
agents submits functional
and non-functional
requirements to our backend
and backend produces outgoing results.
So it'll take some time,
so I'll switch forward to show
how it looks like.
So when agent submitted the
information to our backend,
it receives a job ID that agent can use
to first of all check the status of a job;
and the second, it can use this job ID
to get the results of the processing.
You can see that agent is instructed
to check status periodically time to time,
and it keeps iterating until it see
that the status of job is
changed to complete it.
It means that backend finished
the processing of a job,
and our agent can receive the results
using the separate get results call.
Let's fast forward
and see what did we get from our backend.
So our backend intelligence
hub produces the result,
which consists of two main parts.
As we discussed before,
we have two different workflows
for internal and internal data.
So our outgoing documents
are structured the same way.
We have a first part of the document,
which list all the components
our experts evaluated,
and produced a shortlist.
We can see that top asset identified is
AgentCore Runtime Blueprint,
which is our internal blueprint,
which guides agent on how to build
and deploy agents on AgentCore.
Our sample project is
involving development of agent,
and that's why this
blueprint is determined
as a strong fit for this application.
If I scroll down, I can see...
Sorry, where is it?
We can see the whole
shortlist of the components,
and for each component we can see
break down of expert evaluations
as well as summaries of all the experts
where certain components fits
with target architecture.
And at the end of this document,
we have a block of data
associated with deep research analysis,
so once deep research
analysis is completed,
it adds the results
into the same document.
So now our agent have following documents
and it has access to
functional requirements documents
to non-functional requirement documents
and the results of our
intelligence hub evaluation.
And on the next stage,
agent will generate system architecture.
I forwarded to the end of stage three,
so now I have system
architecture generated.
So we can see it's
quite detailed document,
which describes all the
layer of architecture
with recommended services.
In our sample project,
we asked to generate
serverless applications.
So most of the services are represented
by serverless AWS components.
When we have our architecture generated,
our next step
is to check what is the quality
of architecture generated?
We have quality assurance step
where our agent instructed to perform
quality analysis of package
of the documents to determine
if we can consider this
package is finalized,
or we need to do one more
iteration over this package.
So our agent evaluates the package
across five weighted categories,
like requirements, architecture,
security, implementation, and so on,
and finally produces a final score.
If the score of a package
is below the bar that we predefined,
it means that the agent will need to do
one more iteration of
requirements refinement
and regenerate the requirements.
If the package exceeds the
bar in terms of quality,
we can consider that architecture
is successfully generated,
and we can move to the next stage.
Next and final stage of our
process is security assessment.
You may ask, why we are
doing security assessment
after architecture generation?
With security assessment produces
package of the documents for
our delivery security review,
which is a step in project delivery
when AWS Professional Services
provides this set of documents
for security assessment
by our application security specialists.
And our agent generates
this package of documents
that it significantly simplify us
work for our consultants.
So you can see that we have generated
threat analysis document,
which identifiers risks
associated with certain components
we identified for implementation.
We have security controls
as a set of controls
we need to implement in order to make sure
that application is secured,
and the set of tests
that are required to implement,
to make sure that security controls
are properly configured and applied.
That's pretty much it for this agent.
Today we are demonstrating
first agent from a group of agents
we are building for Professional Services.
This one is a design agent that processes
project requirements and
generates specification package.
The next stage in this process could be,
first of all, this
package can be handed over
to delivery team to
implement the functionality
or this package can be a source
of the data for the next
agent, the build agent,
which can use this information
to automatically build a solution.
If you're interested to see
this built agent in action,
please join us at AWS
Professional Services kiosk
where we have demonstrations
for this agent
and other agents.
And with that I will hand
it over back to Heitor.
- [Heitor] A few final comments is,
as you're gonna see,
like those coding agent
is helping us build things
at lightning speed, and
it's changing the dynamics.
It's not a driving exercise anymore,
it's a launch experience
'cause if you don't plan this properly,
most likely you're gonna go very fast
to the wrong direction.
And it's that's why now it's
more important than never
that you plan your project properly.
So when you launch with vision,
like the agent gonna land
where you need like with precision.
With that, we're gonna open for questions.
Please fill out the form at the end,
and if you need to dive
deeper on the topics
that we discussed here,
this is the QR code that you
have some learning there.
But we gonna, we have some,
around 10 minutes for questions.